Now, let's discuss some details
of intrusion detection.
First, what are the key design elements
of an intrusion detection system.
First, for
intrusion detection to even be possible,
we need to make some
important assumptions.
First, we can observe system and
network and user activities.
Second, from the activities
that we can observe, normal and
intrusion actions have distinct
evidence, that is, for
intrusion detection to even be possible,
we must be able to find evidence of
intrusions by observing systems,
networks, and user activities.
When it comes to designing
an intrusion detection system,
we must consider the following.
>From the point of view
of detection algorithm,
we must consider the features,
meaning how do we capture and
represent intrusion or
normal activity evidence?
We must also decide
the detection models.
Meaning, how do we piece
the evidence together, so
that we can decide whether
an activity is normal or intrusive.
The system architecture typically
includes several modules including
audit data processor,
a knowledge base, a detection and
decision engine, and alarm
generation and response mechanisms.